[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute meinen
leckersten vanille skript boden und
daher sage ich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge von kies buck schule gab es lange
nicht mehr weitergeht buck schule mache
ich halt immer so basics einfach so
rezepte auf die ihr immer wieder
zugreifen könnte ich zum beispiel in
meinen rezept videos auch immer wieder
nutzer und dann ist das rezept video hat
dementsprechend nicht so lange und ich
verlinke immer auf dieses video für
meinen biscuit boden werde ich
zuallererst ein trend für euch ist
wichtig ich werde alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben hier unten in die infobox
schreiben und zum eier trennen müsste ja
auch wirklich gut aufpassen dass ihr da
kein eigelb ins eiweiß
rheinischen lass das muss ganz sauber
getrennt werden
[Musik]
zur weiß masse geben wir dann noch eine
prise salz schlangen das auf maximaler
geschwindigkeit erst mal eine minute
geben denn die hälfte des zuckers mit
dazu und schlagen dass weitere zwei
minuten bis es zu so einer festen masse
wird die andere hälfte des zuckers
brauchen wir jetzt gleich für unser
eigelb und apropos eine ganz wichtig ist
jetzt dass wenn ihr hier auch ein
bisschen eigene drin hätte dann würde
die masse licht so schön steif werden
das muss wirklich fettfrei sein und auch
darauf achten dass ihr keine spülmittel
reste et cetera an der schüssel habt und
so kann jetzt eigentlich weitergehen ich
nehme jetzt den schneebesen ich spare
mir jetzt auch den spülgang nehmen wir
einfach eine neue schüsse und schlag
dann ein gelb mit dem restlichen zucker
und auch schon mal vanille extrakt für
drei minuten an die cremig
nur drei minuten später wie die eigelb
masse schon ganz anders aus als es
richtig schön hell cremig geworden ich
räume jetzt kurz die küchenmaschine weg
übrigens könnt ihr das ganze auch mit
dem handrührgerät machen dann dauert es
wirklich nur so pro schüssel zwei
minuten länger also ist auch kein
problem nachdem ich ihr den weg geräumt
hat machen wir direkt weiter ganz ganz
wichtig jetzt verwendet ihr bitte ein
teig schaber und kein schneebesen mehr
das den einfach dazu dass wir jetzt die
baiser masse auch in mehreren schritten
mit ganz viel
liebe sage ich ja immer wieder
unterheben also wirklich in kleinen
schritten und streicht ihr die eigelb
masse einfach so von außen nach innen
und merkt dass die baiser masse
irgendwann mit dem eigelb 1 wird
[Musik]
so die eimasse ist jetzt gut miteinander
verbunden und jetzt kommen die trockenen
zutaten ins spiel da habe ich hier
mehlspeise stärke und backpulver
eigentlich sagt man bei diskret boden
muss teilweise auch gar kein backpulver
rein ich habe hier wirklich eine kleine
menge und ich finde dass das bei dem
rezept einfach noch mal ein bisschen
besser funktioniert weiß er noch mal ein
bisschen besser aufgeht auch wenn der
teig so schon sehr flüssig ist und um
das ganze noch mal zu bestärken sie sich
alles nochmal in die masse hinein und
das auch in mehreren schritten als jetzt
nicht alles auf einmal passiert auch
dass die masse jetzt minimal einen sinkt
das ist ganz normal aber wichtig ist
dass ihr euch das auch als aufteilt in
ungefähr vier bis fünf partien
[Musik]
so ich bereite jetzt meinen tortenring
vor dafür nehme ich mir ein backpapier
und legte es untendrunter ihr könnt das
ganze dann einschlagen damit auch unten
drunter nichts verläuft im notfall das
macht ihr indem ihr einfach immer wieder
das backpapier an den rand knickt und am
ende ist das so ein stabiles gerüst ihr
könnt natürlich auch eure springform
verwenden das ist gar kein problem ist
macht auch von der backzeit überhaupt
keinen unterschied bei mir ist es so ich
mache das immer einfach je nach laune
nach lust und laune und heute nehme ich
meinen tortenring für das einen der es
auf 26 cm übrigens eingestellt da
erhaltet ihr dann drei böden oder zwei
dickere
[Musik]
den biss mit boden dann bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen für 35 minuten backen ich habe
ihn jetzt hier schon aus dem ofen geholt
und unter einem tuch vollständig
auskühlen lassen
und ich will sieht wunderschön aus ich
nehme jetzt hier nochmal backform löser
das ist halt immer super praktisch wenn
ihr euch den kuchen an den seiten nicht
kaputt machen möchte indem er den
tortenring entfernt daher einmal hier
entlang fahren dann den tortenring
entfernt ich stürze dann den bisschen
boden auch immer er ist auch super
stabil und entfernen auch das backpapier
unten drunter
so dass es wirklich mit abstand der
beste biscuit boden den ihr machen
können das rezept habe ich mir vor circa
fünf oder sechs jahren mal überlegt da
habe ich mit den mengenangaben ein
bisschen variiert hier und da
experimentiert und so mache ich den seit
jahren komplett unverändert habe ich nur
bestätigen
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel freude
beim nachbacken was sich hier austoben
das seht ihr dann immer im nächsten
video wird auf jeden fall sehr lecker
und dann würde ich mal sagen bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]